Lauren Bushnell and Chris Lane are
married there's no doubt in my mind that
she was 1,000,000% created for me
created for my personality I feel like
we're absolutely the most perfect match
ét first broke the news that The
Bachelor alum and country singer were
dating back in November 2018 how'd you
know that she was the one you know what
it's been so easy she makes me laugh so
hard we have so much fun together it
quickly became clear these two were
head-over-heels for one another Chris
even spoke about proposing at the 2019
ECM awards in April engagement news any
time soon you know what I'm working on
it
don't tell her that though yeah you
think is gonna happen I don't know next
year oh yeah I'm gonna ask her to marry
working on it was an understatement the
proposal came not long after when Chris
put on a private concert for Lauren
playing her a new song called
big big plans in the backyard of her
family's Oregon home
[Music]
[Applause]
et spoke with Chris shortly after the
proposal I mean are you just on cloud
nine right now
I am certainly um I did not expect the
response that this song has gotten in
the video is well
I mean it's blowing me away at this
point I've never had a song react the
way that this one is early on and I'm
just glad that people liked it and glad
that they liked the proposal and
everything that went along that day
because I was a nervous wreck he has the
biggest heart like he thinks about he's
the most empathetic person in the entire
world he thinks about my needs before I
even know that I need something which is
so nice
[Music]